and who knows maybe sherman still does
come back to seattle which would make
for some high drama
in 2021
look you know the one thing that's lost
in this
is that richard sherman would make the
seahawks
better in 2021. you're not signing
richard sherman
nobody's going to sign him for three or
four years unless
they're avoidable years you know on the
bottom of the contract
so you know as i look at this
with the richard sherman thing i see it
more in
in um in a more innocent way i mean the
effect of it could be that you're right
mike
but i see it in a way like hey listen
we just lost griffin even though he's
not a great cornerback
but he signed with jacksonville we are
ranks at the corner position right now
are not good and to get richard sherman
even if he only makes it through six or
eight games
that would improve us significantly on
the outside
wouldn't you be better off though
waiting to see what you get in the draft
maybe you get a younger guy that's got
full tread on the tires who comes in and
maybe develops into someone who would be
as good as where sherman is right now
because he's he's clearly on the decline
peter the question is how much is left
in the tank
yeah but mike when you're the seattle
seahawks and you have
three draft choices and your first one
isn't until the 50s
um to think you can count on
a guy who's drafted either on the second
or third day of this draft
and to think that that guy can step in
and to give you
anything in september like what richard
sherman could
is just not intelligent so
that's the only reason i mean and look i
have no idea if they could either afford
him or if they could work out one of
these contracts where
they would you know do four fake years
on the end of
a one-year deal that's probably the way
they'd have to do it
but the only way that they could
you know that they would realize
this or or the only way i think they
would be able to do
anything with a young cornerback is to
trade up and i just don't see that
that john schneider has either the
ammunition or anything i mean
his next two ones are gone there
has been not significant interest in
sherman since he became a free agent the
saints at one point were mentioned
i don't know if that ever went anywhere
john gruden openly tampered with sherman
back before free agency started
the raiders haven't emerged do you
attach any significance peter to the
fact
that robert sala the defensive
coordinator in san francisco during the
entirety of sherman's time there
is the head coach of the jets and has
not made a b-line to try to bring
sherman in to
teach the system to younger players and
give him a veteran presence in the
locker room and just basically be
eyes and ears and and mouthpiece for
what saul is trying to do
no question i do apply uh an
upraised eyebrow to that and look the
way the jets work robert saleh is going
to have to convince joe douglas
if he wants somebody to come in because
joe douglas has got final personnel
say you know it's sort of like in a
weird way the way john schneider had to
convince pete carroll
in 2012 about russell wilson
because pete carroll had final personnel
say
you know in the draft that year so you
know to me
i think this is one of those situations
where robert salah had x numbers about
x number of battles that he could fight
and i just don't think that
he wanted to go to the wall for richard
sherman because
for whatever reason and look he loves
richard sherman and richard sherman
loves him
and so i don't know the story behind it
maybe sherman said look
i'm not coming east i'm not leaving my
family back here
i'm not moving everybody back there it's
a pandemic blah blah blah i don't know
but i do think that it's curious to me
that that solid didn't go hard after
richard sherman
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports